hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
livestream our 11th in a series I'm
sitting with dr. Heather Hein we are
facing very frustrating technical
difficulties some of you are finding
that your stream is not synched up
between audio and video let's see where
should we start we should start with
what we are not going housekeeping but
are calling maintenance um and we have a
couple of announcements in the
maintenance category we will be live in
a presentation for the James Madison
program at Princeton tomorrow and this
is going to be done through zoom there
are a total of a thousand spaces
available I don't know how many are left
but we certainly think it would be a
great idea for people to sign up we will
provide a link to sign up you can also
look at our Twitter feeds and we have
each broadcast the announcement this is
able to put the screen up for just a
minute for my computer this is going to
be I think quite an interesting
presentation for people we are going to
cover some deep issues in the meaning of
consciousness we are gonna provide a new
model and because this is going to the
James Madison program and it's being
broadcast publicly this will all be done
in English rather than science ease so
people who are interested in that topic
but fear that we may end up in a mode
that is difficult to understand I think
you'll be pleasantly surprised we have
every intention of making this
presentation off the hook and by the way
for our young viewers off-the-hook is a
reference to phones and what it means is
in the old days used to come in the door
and you would hang your phone on a hook
also phones were the size size of
Volkswagens so it was a very different
world all true all true yeah by the way
we have a question which is what the
hell are we gonna wear for a
presentation for a Princeton audience
when we're streaming from here our usual
mode isn't gonna work isn't it I don't
think so because
ordinarily you have an audience like
this maybe you for me I would maybe wear
a blazer and a tie right and jeans and
that way you know there's a kind of a
formal note in an informal note and
people can see what they need to see but
online nobody sees that you're wearing
jeans it just kind of looks weird blazer
and bandana that's a thought what I was
thinking about was I could wear a suit
but no shirt oh yeah oh no no no okay I
don't think anyone should try to pull
that off
we'll talk about this later okay all
right other announcements
not as far as I know not as far as my
technical problems resolved and we can
we can just do this yes if you out there
in our audience believe you know what
the technical problems might be they all
seem to be downstream of our PC either
our internet connection or YouTube seems
to be causing this discontinuity anyway
we'd be very interested to hear about it
if there was a fix that you were aware
of that you think we might not be all
right all right should we go and do it
on to the content all right so we've
begun doing Corrections and addendums
and such at the end so we're gonna save
a few few of those things for the end
we're gonna spend most of the time today
talking about this video that many of
you will have seen that had almost 5
million views from two doctors in Kern
County California
Bakersfield hatchapee area south end of
the Central Valley of California which
is you know the producer of much of the
nation's produce and you know it's about
an hour long here you can put this
screen up here for a moment just Zach
just for like 20 seconds here they are
this will give those watching it visual
don't know if they've seen this or not
it's a dr. Erickson these are both MD is
a former emergency room physician who
now co-owns accelerated Urgent Care in
Bakersfield California with dr. I'm
gonna butcher how to pronounce his name
art in massive also an MD and about this
video
you on musk said on Twitter Doc's make
good points
Elon Musk who has been dismissive of the
aggressive actions towards the situation
since early on yep and this is totally
consistent with that so I would say to
mas get a grip man get [ __ ] grip
you're smarter than this seriously
get a grip not be grip sure the the
whole video this whole video is a
terrific example frankly of motivated
reasoning and we're gonna spend some
time dismantling it before we talk about
what it does have going for it the
supporting players if the whole thing is
about motivated reasoning the supporting
players I would say our bad math
internally inconsistent argumentation
inflammatory and dismissive language and
appeals to Authority so it's got all
that in just about an hour let's let's
go let me see if I can just pull up
don't show anything here Zack on the
subject of bad math there are a number
of places with this specifically dr.
Erickson the main the main guy sitting
at the end of this long table they
called a press conference so they've got
a bunch of journalists off screen
occasionally interrupt and occasionally
asking questions but it's mostly these
two guys you've got dr. Erickson
specifically arguing that lockdowns and
aggressive social distancing measures
had no effect and he's comparing numbers
from place to place specifically at some
points he uses numbers from Norway
California the entire state not just
Kern County or Bakersfield and Sweden's
he's got Norway California and Sweden
Norway in California both have and had
pretty restrictive lockdowns can of
course we know in California had the
first three or five counties to
implement lock downs at all in
California itself as a state went wet
towards a pretty severe state of
lockdown pretty early as did Norway
apparently and Sweden did not so we
didn't I had a little bit of social
distancing but kept it schools open kept
you know it kept a lot of things as
normal
and so Erickson says you know but look
at the numbers there's basically no
difference between them he says for
instance and I'm just gonna read through
some of his numbers and then later we'll
come back to his numbers shortly
he says Sweden with no lockdown has
15,000 15,000 plus cases 74,000 tests
therefore 21 percent of the tests were
positive in a population of about
10-point for a million he says let's
extrapolate out the data this is the
phrase he uses we've got about two
million cases in Sweden ok leave that
aside for the moment in Norway which
does did have a lockdown there are a
little over 7,000 cases with 145,000
tests if you're keeping track of the
numbers that's twice as many tests and
only four point nine percent tested
positive now that right there right away
should be raising questions how is it
that neighboring countries with similar
cultures please forgive me Swedes and
Norwegians for all of the differences
I'm sure there are but with relatively
similar cultures how is it that you had
21% testing positive in Sweden whereas
only less than 5% were testing positive
in Norway the clear best answer to this
is different testing protocols and in
fact what we see is that Norway tested
way more people in a population that was
basically half the size of Sweden so
they effectively tested four times the
number per capita of what of what Sweden
tested extrapolating out again to use
Erickson's language he's as well there
must have been about 1.3 million cases
and only 182 deaths
okay so Norway 182 deaths Sweden 1765
deaths he says let me find the actual
quote from him he says the death camp
from Norway and that from Sweden is
statistically in significantly different
he never shows any numbers I mean he
never he never does any inferential
statistics which is exactly what you
would need to do in order to demonstrate
that there was a no difference between
them and in fact we don't have the data
with which to do inferential statistics
we don't even have sufficient data to
you descriptive statistics which would
be to say
averages and standard deviations and
such so first issue with with just
disingenuous math that is motivated by a
conclusion is Norway is testing many
more people and so is getting a lower
test positive positive testing rate as
we would expect so assuming that those
numbers four four point nine percent
positive versus twenty one point twenty
one percent positive and Sweden are the
actual numbers is is very unlikely to be
true one of those numbers at least is
likely to be wrong and given what we're
seeing in a lot of other cases it's more
likely to be that Sweden's numbers are
wrong the idea that twenty one percent
of the population is in fact infected is
more likely to be wrong but it doesn't
matter if either one of those numbers is
wrong comparing them is like comparing
apples to Subarus
so let's be clear though you are
conjecturing that what we have going on
here is motivated reasoning when we
clearly have going on here is
unjustified comparisons of two data sets
that are not alike yes why we have that
we don't know but we do know that the
video and many of you will have seen
part or the whole thing in fact many
people asked us to comment on it mm-hmm
the video very clearly advocates for a
relaxation of the restrictions that we
are living under with lockdown on the
basis that it is not justified by the
numbers and in fact points to a an
analogy with the flu and makes the
argument that this is not so much more
serious than the flu that we ought to be
taking drastic action right so just the
other the the only other particular math
point and there are several other points
that that we want to get through here
but with regard to the math there are
many concerns he doesn't acknowledge
what false positives positives are gonna
look like and how they're going to be
revealing the data and such but the
different very different results from
Norway and Sweden suggest that at least
one of those numbers is wrong and
therefore we can't be doing the
comparison as he's trying to do them
exactly as you just said Bret and then
we have this death count in Norway being
182 versus the death count in Sweden
being 1765 with different background
population numbers Sweden has roughly
twice the number of people as Norway
does quote dr. Erickson Erickson the
bottom line is from those of us who
study it and have a background in this
is lock down versus non lock down didn't
produce a significantly different number
of deaths that is the bottom line
Wow so that is bad math and appeals to
Authority so no no and no all right so
we bad math appeals to Authority and
it's all plagued by small n am I wrong
about that mmm no you mean you're not
you're not wrong inherently they didn't
do a tiny number of testing oh I see if
I can scroll back to fine you know one
hundred and forty five thousand tests in
Norway seventy four thousand in Sweden
it's true it's true that we're still
pretty early in this but I don't I don't
know that the small and is particularly
there are a lot of problems with the
math here but I would put small and
pretty low ungrazed to complaint maybe
better would be suspect and because we
don't know the protocol that generated
write these numbers so that's how that's
that's why you can't trust the
comparison between the positive testing
rates but in terms of the death count
and you have seen people argue oh
there's some you know some places where
deaths are being missed and there's some
places for deaths are being
misattributed to cope in nineteen where
they should be attributed to something
else maybe in both cases but I that
looks like more noise than some kind of
a systemic error or a system systemic
error error so the fact is he didn't do
any statistics so he has no basis on
which to say that there's no
significantly different number of deaths
and I did just a little bit of simple
math that you can do with the numbers
he's provided us and he also then talks
about California so let's just talk
briefly about deaths per capita that is
deaths using his numbers per capita
using numbers that I found on world
population review.com
you know how many people are in Sweden
now how many deaths were they what's the
death per capita in Sweden Norway
California well in Sweden 1.75 times 10
to the negative fourth is the deaths per
capita it's tiny right but in Norway
which did have lock downs in place it's
three point three six times 10 to the
negative fifth and you don't actually
need to remember any math - no -
remember much math to know that that
different exponent 10 to the negative
fourth versus 10 to the negative fifth
means that Norway actually had an order
of magnitude fewer deaths almost then
Sweden did
similarly California's deaths per capita
was 3.0 five times 10 to the negative
fifth Sweden's California's deaths of
norway's deaths that put down lockdowns
early had death rates per capita in the
10 to the negative fifth range and
Sweden in the tentative negative fourth
range both pretty small but these
doctors are not arguing that we I could
see an argument I could see a doctor
saying you know what we just have to put
up with a certain amount of death and
the lock downs are costing us too much
and we are going to have to come out of
lockdown and and deal with the fact that
people will die what they are claiming
is that there's no difference in the
death rate between situations where
there were lock downs and situations
where there weren't and all you have to
do is take the very numbers that they
presented but they fail to do the actual
analysis the simple calculation that
needed to be done and see that actually
of the three examples that they provide
Sweden with no lock down had about an
order of magnitude more deaths per
capita than either Norway or California
did which implemented lock downs early
so we don't know that they failed to do
the calculation we know they failed to
present it and we don't know why but we
we are left with a difficulty that I
have now begun to see comparisons that
correct for all of the hazards in these
sorts of comparisons emerge in fact
BuzzFeed of all places not my favorite
publication but BuzzFeed presented a
pretty good comparison
between sweden and denmark and what it
did was it focused on I guess the term
is excess deaths where in a particular
time period from one year as compared to
the next within the same population and
the question is how many people would be
expected to die during let's say January
and how many people died during this
January and this controls for the oh but
did they actually die of code 19 right
it actually controls for almost
everything because it compares two years
and you could have two years that were
wildly dissimilar but they won't tend to
be wildly dissimilar all over the globe
in the same direction you know to the
extent that the weather is harsh or
something and it has some little effect
it will tend to be swamped out and it
will go in different directions in
different places but these the
comparison between Sweden where my
understanding is there basically was
voluntary measures social distancing was
widespread
there was no lockdown but people were
basically making some effort not to
transmit the disease but they were not
being required to behave in particular
ways compared to Denmark where there was
a lockdown actually shows a strong
preference for Denmark's model based on
excess deaths that show up in Sweden and
not in Denmark so this kind of
comparison is really important also I
mean it's not all clean
New York has shown a massive rate of
excess deaths like a shocking number six
times the number of deaths expected in
this time period something like that and
you know what this points to is all that
we don't know about what the factors are
that are causing this so there's also a
question of when the virus actually
showed up in a particular place right so
one of the nice things about the
comparison with like Denmark and Sweden
as you were just talking about or or
Norway in Sweden so the years are
geographically close enough that we can
expect that more or less the virus
showed up there at the same time the
climatic and weather conditions were
more or less the same it's
whereas in New York it seems New York
like LA it seems that to be increasingly
apparent that actually the virus was
there much earlier than anyone knew and
so even though California experienced
pretty stringent lockdowns and New York
City still does probably those those
lockdowns just came too late to stop the
spread to the degree that they needed to
stop it and so I mean we'll get back to
this but there was a question last time
about India and what's going on in India
one of the one of the likely answers is
it got there late I got there far later
than it did for much of the rest of the
world after the rest of the world was
already seeing it responding to an India
could see the responses India could
implement stricter lock downs far
earlier in a process even though it was
later in the calendar year than other
countries were doing it so you know time
is not absolute with regard to
responding to a virus shows up in
different places at different times yeah
actually the map you showed last time
gave you a time series for where it
jumped which gap at what point and you
know in some places it jumped gaps
multiple times in fact that will have
been commonplace
so yes the clock didn't start at some
moment exactly I mean it did the
original clock right you know the
original virus and there's no left from
a bat or escaped from a lab you know
whatever it was at some moment but
beyond that it is now spreading we've
got effectively an adaptive radiation of
this virus and each fork is at a
different moment in time in a different
place in space yes comparing populations
to each other the clocks start at
different moments but as your original
point here was if you take two countries
that are close together and have close
contact and it makes sense that their
clock would start similarly and so
therefore comparing one to the other
might tell us something about behaviors
at the very least what this seems to be
telling us is that it is not a clear-cut
case the way these doctors have
presented it that argues in favor of the
relaxation of these measures he said now
I would say we do have to do the
analysis the kind of analysis that they
are doing as many people are asking us
to do the analysis that says at what
point
are we willing to accept an excess
number of deaths in exchange for the
reboot of the economy for example so but
that is not the analysis they're doing
though as you know as I was trying to
point out they could be saying at what
point do we need to accept an excess
number of deaths because otherwise so
many other things are going to happen
that are going to cause excess deaths in
other areas but they are actually hiding
behind fake math and claiming that the
the measures that have already been
implemented are not effective and that
is quite a different a different
approach and the reason to walk us
through some numbers was to demonstrate
that it's actually just not true
and that if these guys are MDS and now
you know successful entrepreneurs I hope
that they actually can do the very
simple math to know that in which case
they're lying and we don't know that but
it seems pretty clear that they could do
the basic math that I just did yeah I
mean we obviously have to be careful we
have no idea what's motivating them the
fact that their reasoning appears
motivated is an indictment of the
analysis that they're doing and the fact
that this was seen by some five million
people or so is important because let's
put it this way lots of us are waiting
to hear some message that resonates with
our priors what we expect is going on
and there we know there are millions of
people waiting to be told the danger is
past or it wasn't real to begin with and
it is time for us to go back to doing
what we did and you know frankly I think
we have to be sympathetic to that
perspective you know you and I are lucky
we live in a place where this isn't so
terrible but we can easily imagine the
desire to get back to me I mean I'm
going here and as I said at the
beginning like like with the Santa Clara
County paper the sural at the serologies
paper that we've talked about in a
couple of life casts already I think
that the methods and in this case the
message and the analysis being on the
message are crap but that doesn't mean
that I disagree with everything in it so
we're gonna we're gonna get here too
the many ways that I think actually some
of what they're saying makes sense but
they really undercut their message by
going about it in this disingenuous way
well so we need a rubric and I would say
my rubric I would guess it is yours is
that to the extent that somebody
provides you an analysis that appears
motivated to a particular conclusion
trying to sort through it and find the
wheat and separate it from the chaff
does not make sense one should assume
that a source that is motivated may be
able to say things that you won't spot
so I would just say to the extent that
what we're finding is that this analysis
does not stand up to scrutiny that
already sends up enough red flag that
even if some of the points are right we
should probably find other sources for
them so let's talk a little bit about
hypothesis driven versus data-driven
science and which one of those this
analysis is if either we've we've
alluded to both in this live stream a
few times
in past episodes you want to you want to
just riff a little bit about hypothesis
driven science what it is why we need it
and what data driven science is by
comparison sure so first of all you
should know that you're about to be
dragged into a kind of inside baseball
discussion but you should probably stay
interested because virtually everything
that matters it depends on getting this
right and we've lived in an era where we
have increasingly gotten it wrong this
is a perfect moment to discover the
error science as you all remember from
the chalkboard in grade school or
wherever you first encountered it is a
method that method has one value and
then it has a lot of costs and the
argument of anybody who believes in the
method is that the costs are worth
paying in order to get the value the
value is that it corrects for human
biases and what that means is that if
you think something is true and you run
a proper scientific experiment you will
discover whether or not you were correct
so to the extent that you are bias as
it's true you will
discover it's false if it's false if you
do if you apply the method correctly but
the method actually has deep
philosophical underpinnings and the
philosophical underpinnings basically
require you will remember the method is
you observe a pattern you hypothesize an
explanation for the pattern the
hypothesis makes predictions about what
else would be true if the hypothesis was
correct and then you run an experiment
to see whether the predictions show up
in some place that you look for them
then the part that doesn't frequently
get said is if the test turns out to
reflect positively on the hypothesis if
the predictions are right then the model
that generated it gains strength in our
belief in it and so basically there are
a lot of ways this can go wrong we've
seen the replication crisis take down
entire fields who have generated a whole
library of beliefs that aren't true
because there are ways that you can
apply the method badly and what you do
looks like science but it doesn't
function like it doesn't correct for
bias as it reinforces them especially in
an era of really complicated statistics
where most of the scientists doing
analyses don't actually understand what
the math is behind the statistics that
they're using are so they're black
boxing whole pieces of their research
being pleasantly surprised when out pops
the outcome they were hoping for and
they don't ask too many questions so the
upshot of this is the method is
incredibly sensitive to weather the
people deploying it are actually going
through the motions in which case it
won't work or working hard to discover
their own biases by applying this method
to the patterns in question and so
hypothesis-driven
is I would argue it's the final it's the
ultimate discovery about how science
needs to work do we need to tinker the
methods and the assumptions to get it to
work a little bit er yes but if aliens
step off the spaceship someday and say
we'd like to talk they will have
a version of the scientific method and
we will be able to map our version onto
there's maybe an interesting discussion
to be had but they will be hypothesis
testing they will be falsifying
hypotheses rather than validating them
they will do all the same things why
because it works and you can't expect
anything to replace it so I expect
you'll then go to its challengers yeah
so just to pick up your example those
aliens are not going to have gotten to
earth by using data-driven science and I
always want to put science and scare
quotes when it follows data-driven right
it's what modelers and data scientists
tend to be pushing in this era of big
data where where we have so many numbers
generated at all moments of every day
that can then be queried for what it is
that they might mean by our
supercomputing powers that it seems like
asking the numbers that already exist
for the patterns within them must be a
fine and maybe even a better replacement
for hypothesis driven science but but
it's not right data driven science is
asking data to really reveal patterns
that you did not predict and therefore
what you get out of such queries is a
hypothesis it is not a result it is
often treated like it's a result and
this is how data-driven science actually
you know makes makes its living it
queries it queries data says what do you
see and then whatever is seen ends up
being promoted as this is what we've
found and it is a kind of found but it's
found that hasn't been tested yet that
is effectively an observation which is
something you've said here before right
so if you query data using an algorithm
and you end up with oh I think this
pattern but this pattern has revealed
itself now what you need to do is go
with a hypothesis that there's a pattern
that exists into a different data set
and ask those data if this pattern
exists so I think this is going to be
very mysterious to people until we
unpack it a little bit okay first
data-driven when people say it when they
assert this is data-driven science
let's see what the data say the data are
king right when people do that it sounds
to somebody who has not been in the
trenches like an obvious appeal to the
empirical right oh oh that is almost
synonymous if I say data-driven science
I'm really just saying science with some
kind of emphasis on the empirical this
is not what it is at all it's actually a
kind of coup from empirical meaning of
accountable the quantifiable yeah the
quantifiable and very often the
experimental and we are not arguing
against experiment or empiricism in fact
it is absolutely essential for
hypothesis driven science to be tested
against the empirical that's what makes
it work but if you sideline the
hypothetical and you simply go to a
series of experiments what you are doing
is you are taking all of the parts of
the method that aren't observation and
eliminating them which then fails to
account for bias now the one or two
correct for bias the one caveat that I
would make and people like you and me
hate this point and absolutely domestic
hypothesis driven science could be done
by a machine okay it could be done by a
machine on giant datasets and it would
work now I don't think it would be
artful I don't think we're in a place to
do it but I don't want to say that this
requires people to generate hypotheses
it could be done in a in a mechanistic
algorithmic way it could although many
of you know famously many of the sort of
big-name early twentieth century
scientists like Einstein and others are
on record saying things like and I don't
I don't have any of the quotes on hand
but you know we we do our science with
logic but we invent the the generation
of hypothesis is invention it's
creativity it's dream space you know
it's it's something that you can't teach
that you get experience in by going out
into the world and looking for patterns
and trying to explain them and the
you know sort of rinse repeat you know
wash rinse repeat part in which you're
testing your hypotheses having generated
predictions that necessarily follow from
them and then doing experiments or
careful observations to assess whether
or not they're true and doing the
analysis and going in a circle there can
be taught and people get better at it
over time but the where did the idea
come from is more ineffable and yes you
could teach machines to do some of those
things but many people who actually
generate hypotheses yourself included
myself included well I think still hold
onto the idea that humans yet at least
with the kind of AI we have now are
better are going to be better at
generating new explanations for patterns
in complex systems yes at the moment
humans have a huge advantage in the
creative part of this endeavor which we
under emphasize you know people don't
understand how much of really high
quality science is dependent on the
creative process in the what would be
called the theoretical part of the
endeavor the theoretical part does not
however generate theory it generates
hypotheses which can mature into
theories if they're right and that shows
up in experiment but in any case this is
probably more than you need to know the
key thing to understand is that when
somebody decides to take a shortcut
they are always taking a shortcut in the
direction of empiricism and that
empiricism on its own is prone to all
the errors that science is a cure for in
other words it reflects the biases of
those making the shortcut and that is in
effect what we seem to have found in
this case I was just gonna say what is
it what is it that we have here are they
doing hypothesis driven science
data-driven science neither of the above
sort of sounds like they are pretending
to do data-driven science they are
accidentally acknowledging that they are
not doing hypothetical deductive science
but in fact it doesn't look like
high-quality data either it's not even
right it seems and you know this is I
don't know that anyone else is calling
at this but the the three-part solution
set that I was thinking of and watching
this video was well it's clearly not
hypothesis driven they clearly I'm not
sure they would recognize a hypothesis
if it hit them in the head but they
seemed have facility and really liked
the idea of data but this looks like its
conclusion driven they have a conclusion
they like they're fitting what they find
at that conclusion no matter what
excluding stuff that doesn't fit talking
about the things that does fit that is
actively anti-scientific it it couldn't
really be farther from an actual
scientific approach yep mmm okay so let
us um just walk through a little bit
more in the video before talking a bit
about what points they make that the do
make sense or that are related
what would important things we know
about what this is what kind of have it
this is wreaking that it related to
points they're making they just tossed
it they're making internally
inconsistent arguments for instance they
say that not everyone should wear a mask
because you won't get your good flora
you're not gonna get your immune
response yeah yeah they did so so they
argue that we need exposure to pathogens
in order to strengthen the immune system
quote that's just basic immunology sort
of but not on that time scale I'll tell
you that much yeah so I kind of made a
point of not telling you that particular
thing from the video until so I would
have that reaction on on film yeah and
then they say I mean this this is really
totally remarkable to me and I am
imagining a goal in what they're doing
that may not be fair but they predict
that because they are saying everyone's
masked and so no one is getting the
immunity that they need and therefore
when the lock downs are lifted
everyone's gonna get sick so they've
predicted massive sickness having an
essence you with kovat 19 by claiming
that that's just basic immunology when
that isn't basic immunology not on that
sky
not on that scale and you have two
competing things even to the extent that
your immune system might be able to pick
up exposure to some things at a level
that you don't get sick you're also
being exposed to many things that do
cause you to get sick that you won't be
exposed to if it moves to summer and
those things aren't circulating and
you're not wearing a mask at that point
so anyway that's that certainly I would
say consistent with the hypothesis of
motivated reasoning because they just
cherry picked the part of that argument
that they liked and excluded the part
that goes in the other direction yeah so
then they also say we also complaining
about you buy things at Lowe's they say
you can go to Lowe's you buy things and
you bring them into your home and you're
not blocking transmission of all the
fomites fomites being there jarred they
like to use jargon of course to fomites
being all of the little viral particles
that might get you sick so they're
complaining about the things that you
might bring home that have viral
particles on them and at the same time
saying that everyone being messed up is
going to prevent them prevent you from
getting any kind of immune response that
you need so I would ask them which is it
which is it guys we shouldn't we
shouldn't wear masks because they're not
fully protective and or because they're
too protective
like if you're arguing both and I've and
I've seen what looked like good faith
arguments on both of those you shouldn't
wear masks well actually have not seen
because they're too productive but
because they're not fully protective I
think it's a stupid argument but I've
seen people make that argument in good
faith but these guys seem to be making
both arguments simultaneously you
shouldn't wear them because they're not
protective enough and because it's
you're protective and if you're arguing
for both of those positions it seems
pretty clear than you're arguing for a
conclusion rather than trying to figure
out what's true so that's just one
example of internally inconsistent
arguments and let's do one more set of
things reasons to distrust what's in
this video before we talk a little bit
about things that that make sense they
are consistently using inflammatory and
dismissive language they call covered 19
a seasonal flu it's not it's not
it's not helpful at all to call it that
we have no reason yet to know if it's
seasonal and it's not a flu
quote-unquote I'm following the science
no and he says this a lot he keeps on
saying I'm just following the science
and he basically is dismissing the
journalists who would ask questions of
him and saying like I'm the scientist
here I'm the doctor
trust me I have the background and boy
do we know a lot of people like that is
how opting the authority channel by
pretending to follow science that he is
then violating if you follow the claims
yeah exactly
he's extrapolating in numbers in ways
that are useful to his conclusion he's
picking and choosing data and appeals to
Authority don't make you right you may
be right
if you appeal to Authority it makes you
look like a jerk and if you were wrong
and you appeal to Authority it makes you
look like an even bigger jerk quote the
truth changes every two hours no it
doesn't what we think is true is
changing right the things that we
understand to be true or changing but
what actually is true is not and also
furthermore truth has actually a time
stamp so this is like pointing out that
spread and to say the Scandinavian
countries happened a different time than
spread into New York unspread into India
so whereas his truth is about what we
think we understand and that is a kind
of a dicey use of the term truth I would
say that we could argue for instance
that humans didn't exist 600 million 6
million years ago and our most recent
common Astor's ancestor which was
something some proto chimp bonobo human
thing did saying that 6 million years
ago we didn't exist doesn't mean that
humans don't exist now so you know this
virus had never met us 6 months ago and
that's true but that doesn't mean that
it doesn't exist now so I don't think
the truth changes every two hours I
think is a cute way of saying what we
believe to be true is rapidly changing
which is so I think it is - but it's
wrapped in this appeal to Authority
yes and I would say to the extent that
he's making that argument that argument
goes in the other direction which is you
would err in the direction of caution
with something this potentially lethal
where the truth had not settled down to
the point that we could even formulate a
high-quality consensus on lots of the
basic issues about how its transmitted
why it's particularly virulent in some
people and asymptomatic and others why
it can be asymptomatic and you don't
seem and you you can still have damage
sufficient to show up on a CT scan of
your lungs weeks later things like that
so the basics have not been established
that suggests we should be very very
cautious there are some extremely
dangerous possibilities that we have yet
to rule out here and until we have ruled
them out we should behave as if they are
still live possibilities because they
are so the truth changes every two hours
maybe but if so then the argument you're
making doesn't fit because the
conclusion would be lethal or
potentially so he also says who knows
what's safe for you you or the
government they are trying to control
you well they may be trying to control
you they certainly seem to be trying to
control us in some regards but this
again makes this error that we alluded
to in our last livestream of conflating
the individual with the population
public health is inherently about the
population and we are asking the
population and all of its members to do
something to protect everyone in the
population individual decisions cannot
be the only thing that we are behaving
based on that is this is what government
is for in order to make decisions that
are that have that effect more than
individuals and that can be used to get
us to do what we need to do when the
problems are bigger than individual
level problems so another way of saying
that is that if everybody makes the
decision that is right for them it does
not produce the same thing that we would
come to if we did an analysis over
what's best for the population and it
particularly dangerous when different
people face different hazards in other
words it might be that some doctors in
Kern County would actually be much
better off if the lockdown was to be
lifted but it might cost lots of lives
in other places and so I would imagine
most doctors would not consciously
accept that trade-off but they might
talk themselves into an argument that
would result in that kind of transfer of
well-being from one population to
another and so the one force that can
deal with that conflict between the
individual level and the population
level is a government built to speak for
the public interest now the problem is
our government is not very well equipped
to do that our government has become
corrupt and inept and so it has done a
terrible job with kovat 19 but that said
it has done a much better job than it
might have mm-hmm how is that could you
give me my computer back Thanks sorry I
lost track there no that's all right yet
more technical problems okay
let's talk a little bit about some of
what they bring up that that maybe make
some sense so can I ask you a question
yeah I think we need to be careful in
doing this we should just say it is not
actually the obligation of an analysis
that discovers a motivated set of
reasoning to find the good at the point
you found a motivated set of reasoning
it may be just simply the right thing to
do to walk away now maybe you have
reasons to raise things that they raise
but I don't think I mean as you already
did like you were you already doing a
lot of this and I want to make sure that
I get to the rest of the points that
you've already brought up here all right
right so they point out the people
delaying other medical procedures may
cause an increase in mortality and
morbidity for other medical reasons we
actually brought this up on one of the
last two live streams yeah
it's probably true that they have a
financial interest in making this point
because what they do is they all
and run seven urgent care clinics which
mostly aren't dealing with kovat 19
patients and mostly other people are
standing away from health care at the
moment and so they're probably taking a
financial hit I'm I'm imagining that
that is true but even even if this is a
message from which they would personally
financially benefit if people could hear
it that doesn't make it untrue people
delaying other medical procedures may
put them at greater risk and certainly
most people are avoiding other medical
procedures another thing that is true
and this is exactly where you were going
earlier is the slowly lifting lockdown
makes sense in many regards in many many
places at this point I would say
including where we are in Portland
Oregon but there's this question that
I'm wondering about and have been since
since people have started talking about
study lifting lockdown is schools are
close to the fall in many many places
including I think in the entire west
coast of the United States so what if
other expectations around work and such
resume what are parents with school-age
children going to do rural care kids are
old enough they're in school but you
know we would do fine so I'm not
actually arguing at this point for you
know what are we going to do but a lot
of people with young kids if the
lockdown start to lift and these are you
know people with jobs that haven't been
able to go to work for four weeks or six
weeks however long it is and now they're
expected to and of course they have to
because they need to start making money
but schools aren't open and maybe camps
aren't open and daycares aren't open
what is it they're going to do so I
would raise and this isn't anything
anything that these doctors were talking
about at all but just in it's possible
and this is you know like I cross my
fingers whatever that's supposed to do
maybe children aren't actually
transmitting the virus so there's a an
article it's not even a preprint but you
know schools are gonna be hot beds of
contagion if if children are
transmitting the virus and so how are we
ever going to normalize fully given that
kids are not just packed together into
small rooms a lot but they're also
terrible it
in track of what are their fingers in
their mucus and such is but there's an
article from today actually no yesterday
April 27th between the science director
of the science museum group in the UK
and Kari Stefansson who is the CEO of
the Icelandic company I feel like I
don't have the entire link there but
suggesting that this is Steffensen who
did a lot of the testing in Iceland
he says what is interesting is that even
if children do get infected they are
less likely to transmit the disease to
others other adults we have not found a
single instance of a child infecting
parents No Wow extraordinary if true and
sucked like such a ray of hope but it
was really bleak lancing extraordinary
of true very unlikely to be general it
could be a pattern but just like are you
saying it could be just Iceland or no no
I mean maybe but let's put it this way
the radical variants that we see between
localities between environments you know
indoor versus outdoor look there is no
way it is possible that this thing is
very hard to transmit outdoors it's not
possible that it never happens right
right so because even the fact that it's
hard to define outdoors in a precise way
that absolutely takes everything out of
the gray area means that this this
cannot be true
so children may be unlikely a rare case
may have a lot of people downstream of
it and so we can't ignore it but I mean
there there are two things I think need
to be said here one the issue of is it
time to lift the lockdown in some places
I am so worried about this and as you've
pointed out we're in Oregon Oregon has a
very low infection rate and a low death
rate but sandwiched between two states
with high right high rates I guess the
point would be if you were gonna raise
if you're gonna lift the lockdown
somewhere we'd be benefiting from it
because we'd be one of the states where
it made the most sense but I'm really
worried about the game theory that
unfolds as part of the the country
remains in lockdown
part of it is not I must say I don't
know what happens when a state is locked
down and its adjacent state isn't locked
down I mean what happens to the states
in and around New York if New York
remains on lockdown for I don't know who
knows six months or something because of
its massive rate of infection which is
presumably related to the very different
way that people in New York City live
just the density of people people
stacked on top of each other in a way
that they aren't almost anywhere else
that and then coupled with no lockdown
in states nearby that might be in a very
different circumstance could result in
people flooding out of New York do you
close the borders between the states
what do you do with the fact that human
beings by their very nature are
constantly checking in with how well
their neighbors seem to be doing in
order to figure out whether to be happy
or dissatisfied are we gonna create
massive waves of dissatisfaction in the
parts of the country that are unlucky
enough not to be able to have their
lockdown lifted this this could turn
into a disaster if we do not get very
careful about how we do it and start
recognizing as you keep pointing out the
difference between individual level
population level if we start we need to
get in touch with the idea of what a
race to the bottom looks like a tragedy
of the Commons and we need to start
figuring out how we're going to address
this so that way you just take a minute
to define tragedy of the comments before
we move on a tragedy of the Commons is a
situation in which the individual has a
large effect on their own well-being and
a small effect on the ability on the
collective so in other words if your
factory decides not to dump waste into
an adjacent body of water it will pay a
massive cost to dispose of that waste
properly it will not save an ocean
because so many people are delivering
their waste to it so and it's it's based
on I mean I'm sure the idea predates
this but Garret Hardin
a biologist in 1968 wrote in science or
nature science science American
biologist wrote and I think that it was
called at the tragedy of the Commons
right and so his sort of allegory almost
from which he then generated this more
general case is that you have a
grasslands that is common and people
living around the edges of it who have
cattle they want to graze and you can
easily over graze grassland and everyone
can see when the grassland is being over
grazed but those eight or nine cattle
owners who recognized that the grass is
being over grazed and who pull back
their cattle in order to protect the
Commons will suffer relative to the one
cattle owner who lets his cattle do
whatever they want the grassland does
get even more over graze than it would
but his cattle win and therefore he wins
relative to everyone else right so this
is a a classic game theoretic hazard
almost all environmental problems mirror
this in one way or another and for us
for us moderns the solution to this
involves rational regulation to protect
the Commons we should point out as long
as we're going here a nobel prize was
earned by elinor ostrom for excellent
work that demonstrated that many
cultures have found ways to protect
against tragedies of the Commons so they
have basically traditions that play the
role of coordinating a population around
their collective interests so they
basically have something that
substitutes for regulation but
nonetheless in the absence of regulation
or some force that is substituting for
it you can trigger these hazards and the
catastrophe that could unfold could be
spectacular in this case so we need to
be really careful now I should also say
lots of people were connected to our
asking online for their saying lots of
people there they're reading are of the
mindset that things never go back to
normal they'd like to read some people
who think it is going to go back to
normal I would ask them to give up on
the idea that things are going to go
back to normal
and I don't mean that they should give
up on the idea of things being good
again but the idea that anywhere we need
to go is back is a terrible error this
epidemic has been a an amazing lesson
and as terrible as it is and as
destructive it as it has been it has
been a lot better than it might have
been so in other words this was awful
but it has also been a gift because it
reveals many many things that we needed
to know many things did some of us were
trying to alert the world to and had a
very hard time because it wasn't
tangible to people now it's tangible and
the question is what are we to do to
solve this crisis and what are we to do
even more importantly to make sure it
never happens again if we go back to
normal it will happen again it's coming
that's right all right one more thing
the dr. Masur says late in the video why
can't you go to the park outside and
walk around but you can't go to Home
Depot and nobody's wearing a mask just
doesn't make sense so this is me trying
to find the good parts of the video and
of course this has been our drumbeat
from the beginning that being outside is
almost certainly one of the best things
you can do and the number of you know
backwards thinking unknownst regulations
and their enforcement's that are
happening all over at least the Western
world as far as I've heard around people
being locked in their homes effectively
because they're told they can't go
outside they're not allowed to because
children in Spain we're actually not
allowed to leave their homes including
if they live in apartments for six weeks
that just got lifted yesterday or the
day before children under 14 that is
appalling
what what but just an appalling way to
have to spend that amount of time if
you're a child when actually getting
outside in the fresh air as long as
you're not standing right next to some
people and yelling and singing is almost
certainly healthier for you okay so I
was in the middle of watching this video
yesterday
broke for dinner and we had we had our
delicious dinner and I think you guys
were finishing cleaning up and I went to
Joe just finished watching it and this
is what I found
Zach you want to pull this up so there
we go
YouTube's at it again this is choose
your own black mirror episode time this
video had at this point four point nine
million views or so it's been removed
for violating YouTube's Community
Guidelines now I've since found its
replacement on its [ __ ] shoot that's
right so you know we'll post it in a
we'll make a pin to comment at the top
of the link to this to this video so
that you guys can find it if you want to
so it's not that it was actually lost as
censorship tends not to do but what kind
of worlds are we choosing between here
you can take it down as I couldn't thank
you yeah this is an amazing an amazing
turn of events and I will say we expect
well I wouldn't say unexpected I mean
for me living this right now watching
this video watching it get four point
nine million views in a matter of days
sorry to interrupt but I didn't see that
coming yep so I should just point out
look at where we are neither of us like
this video at all we think it contains a
destructive viewpoint and what's more it
is seductive for all of those people who
are looking for someone with authority
to tell them it's a fine time for us to
go back to normal
so the video I think is very negative I
know you think the same but YouTube's
taking it down is so incredibly
dangerous as a precedent and I mean I
have a number of things to say about
what I see the dangers and maybe I'll
just start there we have a situation in
which YouTube and Twitter and Facebook
are the public square but they're not
public
they are managed by people a who have
fiduciary responsibilities to their
shareholders and B who have a political
perspective on things now the problem is
what they are trying to do if we take
them at their word him am i right that
the community guideline they violated
was they said things that are in
conflict with what the World Health
Organization have stated that is
apparently on a need-to-know basis you
need to know and I don't need to know
you don't okay all right but the problem
is that you have probably heard that the
cooks are always right and this is an
ironic thing that said amongst
sophisticated people now when people say
the cooks are always right they don't
actually mean the cooks are always right
because most of the cooks are wrong most
of the time but what there are though
they were even wrong all the time
some of them are wrong all the time some
of those need to specialize in it on the
other hand as a bona fide kook let me
tell you some of the cooks are not wrong
some of the cooks are trying to tell you
something new that sounds so wrong that
it's difficult to distinguish from all
of the other stuff that just is wrong
now if you decide that your organization
YouTube is going to pull all of the
stuff that conflicts with some authority
what you are effectively doing is
inscribing orthodoxy as the permanent
state of affairs you are saying this is
the gold standard nobody is ever gonna
beat the who with respect to analysis I
don't mean the food the rock I mean it's
hard to beat the who they were awesome
but but nonetheless nobody's ever gonna
beat the World Health Organization in
terms of the quality of analysis well
you know what that's garbage the who has
already screwed up multiple times on
this front the who is compromised by
corruptions and an aptitude and all of
the other things that we see plague in
government these days and and even if it
weren't it has a model that was really
effective thirty years ago and the world
is changing right and you know the other
drumbeat that we have been on since the
beginning here is look at the comparison
between the establishment and
it's navigation of this novel hazard and
the upstarts who are working quickly
working in the open publishing stuff
that hasn't yet been peer-reviewed and
you know I certainly think that what I'm
seeing is higher quality in the non
establishment places the the Wild West
as it were and what's more I'm seeing
things on the establishment side that
are clearly motivated by things other
than a desire to get to the truth you
know that the belief that masks didn't
work and we should not wear them that
was actually an official conclusion that
it seems to have been generated by
people who really privately were trying
to preserve those materials for medical
professionals and then those same people
told medical professionals don't make
your own mask because it will cause
unevenness in the workplace or something
so we've already seen these people make
terrible errors that kill right in such
an environment the last thing you want
to do is tell people like us frankly you
can't discuss things that are in
conflict with the World Health
Organization we don't trust you to hear
other people's ideas right right we
don't the idea that this video was taken
down it's a video that I find
potentially quite dangerous it's going
to fuel some fires that already exist
that are putting people at risk and yet
it absolutely a hundred percent needs to
be available it needs to be available
needs to be of and the correct response
to it is this one which is all right
let's look at those claims let's see
what they're based on do they stand up
they don't on the other hand let's look
at the idea that you should be filtering
in place and you should not be going to
the park or the beach or taking a hike
right
maybe that's incredibly destructive and
we could afford to lift that one
universally mm-hm so these are things
that need to be discussed and navigated
and shutting down viewpoints cannot
possibly be the right way the censorious
instinct that these corporations have is
so lethal
and especially given some of the crazy
beliefs that are now circulating inside
these entities you know there's no
difference between men and women right
that's a dangerous belief you want a
corporate entity that seems to believe
that's true that will kick somebody off
their platform for saying otherwise you
want them in charge of deciding what
kinds of medical positions or medical
claims we can make no we want the truth
to come out by virtue of the fact that
it is open to critique it is happening
in the open and having heard a critique
any person can go back to the original
source and compare the critique with the
original and with their own emerging
understanding of the situation critiques
can't stand on their own and original
sources need to be able to be critiqued
you need both sides of those things for
human knowledge to progress absolutely
yeah where are we time wise can I just
do a very quick reading you could do a
quick reading and then I have one final
note okay and I wanted to say a couple
things about India as well so I started
reading and I don't know if I'm actually
getting it very far into it because it's
a it's dense and long it's Boccaccio's
the Decameron which was written about
and the Europe emerging though Europe
being in the plague in the 1400s I
believe and early in the book he's
writing about what people's responses
are and now the plague is obviously a
much deadlier disease it's much much
more virulent than Koba 19 that we are
experiencing right now but with regard
to how people responded to people
falling dead falling down dead around
them the author writes in which
circumstances not to speak of many
others of a similar or even graver
complexion diverse apprehensions and
imaginations were engendered in the
minds of such as were left alive
including including almost all of them
to the same harsh resolution to wit to
shun and abhor all contact with a sick
and all that belonged to them
thereby to make each his own health
secure among whom there were those who
thought that to live temperately and
avoid all excess would count for much as
a preservative against seizures of this
kind wherefore they banded together and
dissociating themselves from all others
formed communities and houses where
there were no sick and lived a separate
and secluded life which they regulated
with the utmost care avoiding every kind
of luxury but eating and drinking very
moderately of the most delicate viens
and the finest wines holding converse
with none but one another lest tidings
of sickness or death should reach them
and diverting their minds with music and
such other delights as they could devise
others the bias of whose minds was in
the opposite direction maintained that
to drink freely frequent places of
public resort and take their pleasure
with song and revel sparing to satisfy
no appetite to laugh to laugh and mock
at no event was the sovereign remedy for
so great an evil and that which they
affirmed they also put in practice so
far as they were able resorting day and
night now to this tavern now to that
drinking with an entire disregard of
rule or measure and by preference making
the houses of others as it were their
Inns if they but saw in them aught that
was particularly to their taste or
liking which they were readily able to
do because the owner seeing death
imminent had become as reckless of their
properties of their lives so that most
of the houses were open to all-comers
and no distinction was observed between
the stranger who presented himself and
the rightful Lord thus adhering average
there in human determination to shun the
sick as far as possible they ordered
their life and this extremity of our
city's suffering and tribulation the
venerable authority of laws human and
divine was a based and all but totally
dissolved for lack of those who should
have administered and enforced them most
of whom like the rest of the citizens
were either dead or sick or so hard
busted for servants that they were
unable to execute in the office whereby
every man was free to do what was right
in his own eyes not a few there were who
belonged to neither of the two said
parties but kept a middle course between
them neither laying the same restraint
upon their diet as the former nor
allowing themselves the same license and
drinking and other dissipations as the
latter but living with a degree of
freedom sufficient to satisfy their
appetites and not as wreck losses wow
yeah yes well before the discovery of
the germ theory of disease right all
right well that's fascinating I have a
feeling that that's going to create a
great many fans we're gonna ask you to
read we're as fond of hearing Yuri to
them as I am you experience me reading
quite a lot of yes I do
well you're delightful to listen to it
alright so the final point that I wanted
to make before we take a break
prior to our QA is a follow-up on the
discussion we had last time about the
mystery surrounding the origin of the
virus that causes kovat 19 and in
particular the question of the various
hypotheses surrounding how this virus
got loose in will ha the establishment
has continued from before our live
stream and has continued after to rally
around the idea that all responsible
voices who are informed on this find the
idea of the virus having escaped from
the Wuhan Laboratory preposterous sure
this is actually an NPR story hey Zack
can you put this up this is an NPR story
it's well worth a three minute listen
and basically this is from April 23rd so
before our last live stream maybe before
Yuri Deegan wrote his excellent analysis
which we spent time on last time and
their point is that they have looked
into the question first of all they
blame Trump for the idea that this virus
escaped from the lab when of course lots
of people who are not Trump fans
including us find this hypothesis
credible but their point is this is
clearly a false story and their analysis
comes down basically to two points one
of which is on compelling and the other
one is a lie the first point is these
laboratories are so very careful that
the virus could not possibly have
escaped
now that's garbage and you probably know
enough to know it you know that in
trying to maintain protection from the
possibility of a virus on
something you've touched or this or that
that it is very hard to juggle all of
the things necessary so that in trying
you know if you're wearing something
protective you need to get that off you
need to you you're touching all kinds of
things and the successful protocol
reduces the likelihood of you
encountering a particle to some number
that's very low it can't reduce it to
zero because of all of the things that
you can't control for now the laboratory
may be so good that it maintains
discipline and only very occasionally
does any particle escape but you're
talking about people walking into a cave
capturing bats that are flying around
with potentially who knows what in the
air taking samples swabbing them you
know fecal swabs or whatever getting
them into a vial etc etc you can't
reduce the chances of some particle
making it on to some thing that escapes
notice to zero okay so you can reduce it
low but you can't reduce it to zero and
then there's the part of the analysis
that's just dead wrong
they say by the way these viruses are
immediately frozen a live version of
them is maintained but rarely accessed
and when it is accessed it is often no
longer viable that part may be true but
then they say that these labs are just
studying the genomes right that these
aren't viral particles they're studying
they just sequence the genomes to look
at them and this isn't true the analysis
that we talked about last time talks
extensively about this gain-of-function
manipulations these chimeras that are
designed actually to produce highly
infectious viruses the Chimera being
effectively a hybrid created in a lab
yeah combination two things fused
together so these labs produce these
chimeras specifically because they think
they may be highly infectious and
ostensibly for the purpose of figuring
out what to do if one of them escapes
into the world so they are creating
viable viruses and they are testing them
on various things including live cells
so the idea that we can all just relax
about this hypothesis because scientists
have looked at it and it's not
is nonsense trust them what isn't
nonsense is that there is a spectacular
coincidence about this virus having
emerged in Wuhan and the laboratory
being there that is very hard to dismiss
so could it have come through a wet
market maybe although the evidence for
that is pretty weak is there some other
reason it might have emerged in Wuhan
there could be natural explanation
somebody could be framing the Wuhan lab
there are all kinds of ways that this
could have unfolded but the idea that we
can all just simply put that one to rest
because scientists have looked at it and
you don't need to look any further is
just garbage all right so let's just
connect that up with the last thing we
were saying the establishment wants you
to think you don't need to worry about
whether this might have escaped from
Wuhan of course we need to mean escape
from the lab in Wuhan of course we need
to worry about it because it has
implications for what we do right if
this was a chimera that escaped a lab
that was studying it for the purpose of
protecting humanity then it isn't the
bio weapon we need to know that frankly
if this lab screwed up and this thing
got out I'll be angry that the
regulations and these are frankly world
regulations these are regulations that
the the world's scientific community
imposes on such labs I will be angry
that those regulations were not
sufficient to protect humanity from an
accident like this but I would defend
the lab assuming that they followed the
protocols I would defend the lab as
having made an honest accident that yes
has a huge cost to humanity and will
have killed a tremendous number of
people but an honest accident is an
honest accident if this is something
more than that we need to know yesterday
because we need to understand what it
was that the person who created it had
in mind and if this was natural and it's
really just a coincidence that it
emerged in Wuhan then we need to know
that that this requires us to be able to
discuss it and if YouTube can decide
that we can't discuss the possibility of
lifting the lockdown until the who says
that it's okay for us to discussed and
they could also decide that it is not
okay for us to discuss the possibility
that this virus was a laboratory made
since that at chimera and we could be
eliminated from YouTube and I'm telling
you this hypothesis
exist for a reason because it's a
hypothesis it makes predictions it is
falsifiable if it didn't come from a lab
we can learn that but we have to be able
to discuss it in the open in order to do
all right all right so we are going to
be back in 15 15 minutes in the meantime
we would ask you if you want to support
this podcast please hit like subscribe
notify you can make a comment and we
will be back in 15 minutes to answer
your questions on a live stream whose
leaked link will be in the description
of this live stream see you then